bonsoir vous êtes sur tvfiles 78 pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 lecture le
journal de la rédaction du lundi au
vendredi voici les titres de ce 27 mars
alors que les banques espèrent
développer le paiement sans contact via
la carte bleue une application
permettant de régler sa facture avec son
mobile vient de voir le jour
présentation de tips déjà en service
dans un centre commercial de Rambouillet
à Maurepas 5 listes pouvaient se
maintenir pour le second tour elles ne
seront finalement que trois seulement
les alliances passées font grincer des
dents à droite comme à gauche vous le
verrez à la verrière large victoire pour
le Front de Gauche à linge face à
Nicolas Dainville pour l'Union de la
Droite une victoire plus nettement 2008
que commencera au cours de cette édition
le principal intéressé le président
chinois en France actuellement et ce
jeudi soir à Versailles Jinping doit
assister à un opéra avant de dîner au
Trianon l'autoroute A13 est fermée entre
19h et 19h30 dans le sens Paris
Versailles les principaux axes autour du
château sont interdits à la circulation
et au piétons également Château fermé
exceptionnellement depuis 16h Versailles
habitué à ce genre de réception de haute
dignitaires étrangers le roi des Belges
Baudouin 1er ou encore le président
américain Kennedy sont déjà passés par
Versailles dans l'actualité de ce 27
mars également depuis 2009 la marque
Renault a décidé de renforcer son
activité des concepts cars des véhicules
souvent présentés dans des salons ils ne
sont pas destinés à être commercialisés
mais à montrer les innovations de la
marque et inspirer les futurs véhicules
sur ces images vous voyez un véhicule
présenté aujourd'hui la quid le Quid
pour la première fois le constructeur
automobile a lancé ce concept car
destiné spécifiquement un pays étranger
l'Inde ils sont déjà implantés sur place
une usine à Chanay produit les puls
véhicule adaptés au marché indien et les
Duster qui se sont aussi très bien
implantés ils cherchent avec ce concept
car à gagner donc des parts de marché
dans un contexte économique difficile
pour l'automobile française
on reste encore quelques instants sur
ces questions économiques et cette
innovation donc au centre commercial
belle-air à Rambouillet désormais vous
pouvez payer dans certains magasins du
centre avec votre téléphone romain
garbète et Patrick Jacques de dixmieux
de 600 TCI
ce mode de paiement ne vous dit
peut-être rien c'est une application
mobile qui permet aux clients de payer
directement avec leur smartphone ce mode
de paiement est disponible au Centre
Commercial Bel-Air de Rambouillet
nous inscrivez après l'avoir téléchargé
vous activez votre carte bancaire dans
le cadre d'un processus qui est sécurisé
qui a été revu par les instances
compétentes en la matière et une fois
que vous l'utilisez en fait vous
approchez votre téléphone de
l'équipement du commerçant et on
déclenche la transaction de paiement au
travers d'un son on utilise en fait une
technologie
partant du haut-parleur et du micro du
téléphone le centre commercial Bel-Air
et le premier d'Île-de-France à
s'équiper de ce système
ne se contente pas seulement du paiement
par mobile l'application récompense ses
utilisateurs via plusieurs remises et
promotions dans les différents commerces
partenaires d'ailleurs près de la moitié
des commerçants du centre n'ont pas
hésité à s'acquitter des 10 euros de
cotisations mensuels pour le terminal
nous cherchons un outil de mutualisation
de partage
des promotions et de et de cohésion dans
l'ensemble des des commerçants du centre
commercial pour répondre à des besoins
qui sont les besoins de clientèle de
fidélisation de promotion
d'augmentation du chaland du flux et
puis continuer à être compétitif sur un
marché qui est de plus en plus
concurrentiel au cours de l'année une
dizaine de centres en France adopteront
cette technologie avec l'ambition que
les clients délaissent leur portefeuille
sur l'actualité économique rendez-vous
avec Phil Eco dès 18h30 pour la première
diffusion ce jeudi soir présenté par
Claire Cambier santé à présent c'est un
événement qui a toujours autant de
succès cette année l'Hôpital des
Nounours a accueilli plus de 300 enfants
et des écoles de Versailles de Vélizy
accompagnés comme toujours de leur
doudou malade il parcourt les services
de l'hôpital qui sont tenus par des
étudiants en médecine de l'Université de
Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines Yolaine
Torres pour ce reportage
dans la salle d'attente les enfants
s'occupent et passionnent jusqu'à leur
tour ils sont venus faire soigner leur
nounours
à Versailles dans cet hôpital fictif une
centaine d'étudiants en médecine de
l'Université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines se transforme en nounours ils
ausculté orientent les enfants vers
différents services en fonction de la
pathologie de leurs peluche un événement
organisé depuis plusieurs années par
l'association poème les enfants ont
assez peur d'acheter le médecin parce
que généralement c'est des moments où
ils sont fatigués malades ils sont pas
bien du coup ils peuvent avoir un
mauvais a priori du médecin et le but
c'est vraiment de casser cette image
négative de la blouse blanche et du
médecin et de rassurer l'enfant
vis-à-vis des soins et de l'hôpital on
va lui faire une petite piqûre avec un
petit liquide qui va l'endormir est-ce
que tu veux faire la piqûre
après le stand de consultation les
enfants emmènent leur nounours au poste
de soins au bloc opératoire chez le
dentiste ou encore ici chez les
radiologues on leur montre que la
radiologie ça fait une image de
l'intérieur de leur nounours et on
essaye de leur montrer que ça en fait ça
fait pas mal c'est juste une photo et
que ça prend un peu de temps et que même
s'ils sont tout seul faut pas
s'inquiéter organiser sur une semaine à
Versailles puis à Vélizy l'Hôpital des
Nounours a accueilli cette année plus de
300 enfants
municipales à présent en tête à l'issue
du premier tour à Maurepas Grégory
garestier récupère à présent
l'investiture UMP
udi pour le second face à lui un triom
Michel Chapat Michelet Pierre Le
Guérinel en formé une alliance une
alliance qui fait beaucoup parler leurs
adversaires et notamment Ismaël Avanne
le troisième candidat de ce second tour
Olivier Maylis calco et Elodie moine
amour pas ils auraient pu être 5 à se
maintenir au second tour finalement au
jeu des alliances il ne seront que trois
Michel Chapat candidat divers gauche qui
termine seconde et suffrages le 23 mars
voit arriver deux soutien de poids dans
son camp Michel et sans étiquette
quatrième au premier tour et Pierre Le
guerinel arrivé troisième dimanche
candidat UDA orienté à droite pour
Ismaïla vanne qui se maintient et défend
les couleurs du PS dans ce second tour
cette alliance est une mauvaise surprise
il se trouve que ce soit nous sommes
arrivés derrière Michel Chapat donc
naturellement nous avions vocation aussi
à discuter avec lui puisqu'il se
revendique de divers gauche il a fait le
choix de pas se tourner vers la gauche
mais vert le centre et l'UMP c'est un
choix moi que je trouve très très
étrange et au final peut-être pas si
étranges que ça puisqu'il à mort pas il
y a une confusion des genres depuis
plusieurs plusieurs années ça continue
moi je ne m'associe pas à ça je suis je
continue à être dans clarté de ma ligne
politique et de mes projets un
communiqué de presse l'a annoncé mardi
Grégory garestier candidat divers
droites arrivés en tête dans les
suffrages au premier tour a désormais
l'investiture UMP
udi pour celui qui porte maintenant
seuls les couleurs de la droite à mon
repas le ralliement de Pierre Le
Guérinel à Michel Chapat et beaucoup
moins surprenant c'est une alliance de
circonstances qui ne regroupe que des
intérêts personnels on le voit bien et
j'ai toujours dit pour Monsieur Pierre
Le yinel qu'il n'était pas droite il a
toujours été à gauche il a fait gagner
Georges moujon 2008 et il recommence
alors qu'au premier tour il avait
utilisé l'UDI et parfois un peu l'UMP
contre finalement les instances de l'UMP
si cette alliance fait donc beaucoup
parler pour Michel chappe en revanche
elle défend avant tous les intérêts de
la ville et l'avenir des morpasiens même
s'il reconnaît qu'elle a de quoi
surprendre ça ne manquera pas de
surprendre des morts parisiens et en
particulier celles et ceux qui nous ont
fait confiance
l'important c'est l'avenir de la commune
c'est de décrisper les relations c'est
de dépolitiser par rapport aux partis
politiques de réunir ensemble des gens
qui n'ont pas la même sensibilité mais
qui sont d'accord pour l'avenir de la
commune c'est ce que j'avais fait dans
ma liste du premier tour c'est ce que
nous avons ici de faire dans la liste du
second tour Grégory garesti et Michel
Chapat ou Ismaïla vanne comme prochain
maire de mon repas réponse dans les
urnes ce dimanche la bataille s'annonce
en tout cas serré pour succéder à
Georges Mougeot
je reçois pour cette édition du 27 mars
à jage bonsoir Mr de la verrière élu
avec l'étiquette du Parti communiste
presque 60% des suffrages exprimés 29
sièges pour voir vous en avez raflé 23
c'est mieux qu'en 2008 Pierre c'est
l'incourt qui vous a passé la main en
cours de mandat avec totalisé un peu
plus de 50 %, il y avait plus de liste à
l'époque forcément un mot sur
l'abstention cependant près de 45% comme
au National d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup de
regrets pour vous aussi de voir que la
population a parfois du mal à se
mobiliser pour se scrutin qui est
pourtant l'un des préférés des Français
oui c'est vrai on retrouve d'abord ceci
dit l'abstention à Laverne n'a pas
progressé entre 2008 et 2014 donc c'est
plutôt une bonne chose mais on peut pas
s'en satisfaire c'est un taux élevé un
taux élevé encore plus élevé dans les
quartiers populaires donc ce qui rejoint
un peu l'analyse nationale d'un
électorat un peu fatigué désabusé qui a
du mal à s'accrocher un peu à aux
espérances démocratiques et aux devoir
électorales c'est la première fois que
vous êtes élu en tant que tête de liste
est-ce que qui va changer beaucoup de
choses pour le mandat cette fois-ci et
vous serez totalement libre de mener
votre politique sans
hériter non plus de ce qui avait été
fait par piercelincourt en début du
mandat précédent écoutez on fait
effectivement on fait un beau score 60%
de voix alors que nous avions annoncé
dès le départ notre projet notre
programme un projet un programme
ambitieux qui a pu paraître pour
certains un petit peu un petit peu
difficile à porter
s'engager dans un projet de
développement important une modification
assez importante de de l'organisation de
notre ville nous avions souhaité être
sincères avec nos électeurs ne pas leur
cacher que nous avions des ambitions
pour cette ville et que nous avions un
projet d'ensemble nous l'avons porté
nous avons gagné avec une large majorité
et cette fois-ci justement mener le
mandat tout au long du mandat de A à Z
cette fois-ci c'est plus simple pour
pour diriger une ville en tout cas deux
choses d'abord c'est une aventure
municipale renouvelée municipal
renouvelé c'est une équipe peut-être
adaptée au projet que nous donc avec une
volonté effectivement de renforcer
toutes les démarches de proximité donc
nous avons une liste encore plus
représentative de notre ville de ces
quartiers de cette diversité et puis
effectivement
un projet que qui se voit valider et
donc l'envie là d'engager très vite les
changements et le travail au quotidien
avec les habitants au moment de la
victoire vous disiez vouloir regarder au
mieux les résultats pour répondre aux
attentes des électeurs maintenant que
vous avez un petit peu de recul
justement sur les différents résultats
dans les différents bureaux de vote
différents quartiers quels sont les
enseignements que vous avez tirés est-ce
qu'il y a des enseignements attirés oui
il y a des enseignements il y a toujours
à continuer ce travail de
réconcilier nos citoyens avec la
politique donc c'est ma priorité c'est
ma priorité de notre liste nous allons
évidemment nous y attacher la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on sent bien qu'on
regarde des enjeux que nous portons il
faut continuer d'expliquer pourquoi nous
souhaitons se développements comment se
développements sera équilibré et comment
il va profiter à l'ensemble des
habitants de la ville et on sent bien
que par exemple au village il y a pu y
avoir quelques inquiétudes donc nous
allons évidemment
rassurer expliquer et faire avec il y a
aujourd'hui un grand sentiment de
défiance envers le pouvoir socialiste
vous faites partie de ceux qui demandent
des changements aussi on a pu vous lire
dans une tribune dans Libération
justement pour évoquer ces ce besoin de
changer la politique et d'avoir une
politique cohérente avec un gouvernement
de gauche en fait en quelque sorte c'est
ma position depuis le début donc au
moins je n'ai pas changé je pense qu'il
y a effectivement
une déconnexion entre les attentes des
citoyens et la politique qui est menée
moi j'espère que le gouvernement les
députés majoritaires à l'Assemblée vont
mieux entendre et mieux écouter les
aspirations de nos citoyens et il ne
faut pas une infection il faut un
changement assez radical de la politique
menée il faut d'abord écouter il faut
mieux répondre aux urgences sociales et
puis il faut réconcilier effectivement
nos citoyens avec la démarche politique
ça fait partie de vos priorités
justement parce que vous avez évoqué ce
quartier de développement de la ville de
la verrière qui est important on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler mais au-delà de
ça il y a tout un lien à retisser avec
la population la population des
quartiers populaires aussi pour les
faire revenir aux urnes c'est évident
c'est évident il faut que les citoyens
soient en situation de décider c'est on
peut plus faire leur place c'est terminé
ces époques là et donc faut redonner la
parole aux citoyens faut redonner les
moyens d'action citoyens se traduit
comment dans les faits de politique vous
pouvez mettre en place nous on a deux
trois propositions très simples si
demain nous mettons en place des
conseils de citoyens nous souhaitons que
ces conseils de citoyens et le pouvoir
de proposition et le pouvoir de dire oui
ou de dire non au projet municipaux que
nous présentons c'est-à-dire des vrais
pouvoirs d'intervention sinon c'est pas
c'est pas de la concertation c'est pas
c'est pas de l'implication citoyenne
c'est c'est de la petite salade que nous
mettons et ça les gens n'en veulent plus
maintenant il faut effectivement et la
deuxième chose que nous mettrons en
place ce sont des élus de quartier au
quotidien au contact de nos concitoyens
faire remonter et traiter les
préoccupations du quotidien c'est ça une
urgence être plus attentif à ses
préoccupations du quotidien et enfin il
y a une troisième c'est le débat le
débat public les habitants ont des
choses à dire moi j'étais très surpris
pendant la campagne électorale de voir
que nos concitoyens avaient plein
d'idées et pas que des idées sur les
aspects locaux mais ils ont des idées y
compris sur les grands sujets nationaux
régionaux et sur les politiques à mener
faut les écouter il y a un élément qui
va peut-être un peu changer la donne
dans votre façon de faire la politique
cette fois-ci parce que si vous avez été
lu à la verrière la majorité n'est pas
du tout est loin de là acquise à
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines on l'a évoqué depuis le début
de la semaine avec Bertrand Houillon
lundi le maire de Magny-les-Hameaux avec
François Deligny aussi c'était hier sur
ce plateau eux sont socialiste vous
qu'elle regarde vous avez sur cette
éventualité possibilité et même forte
possibilité de voir la droite remporter
s'imposer pour la première fois dans
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
c'est le jeu démocratique quand on s'y
prête il faut en accepter évidemment les
règles et donc les conséquences c'est
pas complètement grande surprise pour
moi c'était un risque qui avait été
évoqué donc je ne suis pas complètement
surpris que l'agglomération change de
bord au soir du 30 mars c'est pas encore
fait mais enfin si achemine
tranquillement
j'espère et c'est mon souhait le plus
cher c'est que ce que je prône depuis
longtemps c'est-à-dire une coopérative
de ville une agglomération respectueuse
de de la position de chaque ville mais
en même temps défendant un projet
discuté voulu par les mers j'espère que
cette ligne avec les inflexions normales
que j'imagine que la nouvelle majorité
apportera ceci sur le fond prenant en
compte évidemment les disparités les
rééquilibrages nécessaires le
développement à l'ouest de
l'agglomération qui est une urgence et
qui est indispensable et donc j'espère
que l'agglomération continuera
d'accompagner le développement de nos
communes il n'y a pas de raison c'est
pas l'agglomération la majorité
précédente l'a fait et bien fait auprès
les communes quelles qu'elles soient et
quelle que soit leur couleur il n'y a
pas de raison que la nouvelle majorité
ne le fasse pas en tout cas c'est on va
rentrer avec un état d'esprit de
discussion mais le mode de scrutin ayant
changé puisque dorénavant on est lié
donc c'est conseillers communautaires
est-ce que ça veut pas dire qu'il y aura
une politisation plus forte aussi de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce qui n'était
pas le cas jusqu'à présent écoutez on
rentre dans une phase extrêmement
compliquée puisque déjà dans les deux
ans qui vont venir il va falloir
travailler sur la mise en oeuvre de la
nouvelle loi d'organisation des des
compétences et des territoires donc on
va déjà avoir ce travail là donc on
verra bien comment nous allons pouvoir
engager ce débat quels sont les
élargissements possibles de
l'agglomération et quels sont les choix
est-ce que ce sont des choix politiciens
qui vont dominer ou est-ce que ce sont
des choix de cohérence territoriale
développement je prône évidemment des
choix de développement cohérents de
territoire cohérents des territoires de
projet c'est ce que nous défendions dans
l'ancienne majorité si la la prochaine
majorité sur les mêmes positions on
devrait arriver au delà des nuances et
il sait plus que des nuances nous avons
évidemment des divergences fortes la
droite pendant le mandat précédent à
expliquer et affirmer qu'elle remettrait
en cause tout un ensemble de politiques
déjà mises en œuvre sur notre territoire
j'espère que
dans la pratique les choses seront un
petit peu plus nuancées discutés pour le
bien des habitants les verriers rois ont
besoin de l'agglomération nous sommes
une commune qui bénéficion d'une vraie
solidarité communautaire nous espérons
bien pouvoir continuer de le faire sinon
notre commune sera bien difficile à
gérer une dernière question pour que
l'agglomération reste à gauche il
faudrait éventuellement que Luc miserait
parce que j'imagine que vous aussi comme
tous les élus qui sont passés sur ce
plateau vous avez fait les calculs mais
il faudrait notamment que Luc Miserey
arrive deuxième sur trappe et que Othman
nasrol le candidat de la droite termine
3e ou encore que Jean hache le candidat
de la gauche à Voisins-le-Bretonneux lui
aussi il termine en seconde position la
clé c'est la mobilisation aussi je pense
à toi plus particulièrement et puis
votre regard sur la candidature de Luc
Miserey qui est du même bord politique
que vous moi je fais partie de ceux qui
regrettent qui est pas pu y avoir
alliance au moins en second tour entre
les différentes forces de gauche à
Trappes je trouve ces regrettable parce
que ce sont des dynamiques qui auraient
pu inciter les électeurs à voter plus
massivement et effectivement du coup à
être plus plus puissant et donc à rafler
plus de siège puisque c'était l'objet
voilà la réalité politique de trappe
fait qu'il y aura deux listes de gauche
j'espère qu'effectivement il y aura une
forte mobilisation des des reports entre
les différentes voies et que la
candidature les candidatures de gauche
arriveront largement en tête et surtout
qui que l'on mettra un peu un terme
assez assez campagne qui ont été assez
violentes sur le territoire un peu
démagogique un peu un peu fourre-tout
sans projet sans programme mais avec une
volonté de démolir ceux qui avaient des
projets des programmes merci alors
d'être passé sur ce plateau mère de la
verrière et lui donc dimanche après de
60% des suffrages qui se sont exprimés
merci à vous à notre mère et largement
c'est ta Coignières Henri Payet décroche
21 des 27 sièges de la commune face à
Didier Fisher le maire sortant se
présenter pour la première fois sans
l'investiture de l'UMP mais c'est bien
du vent national de contestation dont se
dit victime le socialiste Didier Fisher
Henri Payeux est en place depuis le
milieu des années 80 nous l'avons
rencontré cet après-midi
je mène la même politique depuis 1983
avec le succès que l'on sait j'ai fait
de quoi dire la deuxième brèche la
deuxième vie de la plus riche du
département par habitant en 30 ans donc
c'est pas aujourd'hui je dirais que je
vais remettre en cause la politique qui
la mienne sur la ville parce que je
dirais en cette occasion j'ai perdu 5
points je pensais très sincèrement que
je ferai mieux qu'en 2008 parce que j'ai
un bilan je dirais du mandat qui
s'achait qui s'est achevé tout à fait
exceptionnel avec des investissements
que je n'en ai jamais fait j'ai diminué
qu'il puisait la fiscalité de 10% en
2013 ainsi que tous les services à faire
à la population et donc je m'attendais à
faire je dirais un meilleur score moi je
suis rentré en politique très jeune de
18 ans j'étais à l'époque d'ailleurs le
petit chouchou de Michel Debré le
Premier ministre de l'époque et puis
ensuite j'ai fait de la politique pour
les autres c'est à dire Gédé des
candidats lors de leur campagne
électorale et c'est quand j'a 83 en
arrivant ici à Coignières donc je me
suis investi et très sincèrement à
l'époque je pensais pas du tout j'en
prenais pour 30 ans
et puis j'aime Coignières j'aime les
connais rien c'est une ville extrêmement
sympathique
Marie-Claude Renaud qui était je dirais
qui était en face de moi en 2008 m'a dit
décidément mais comment faut-il faire
pour vous battre
en 2038
donc vous n'écrivez pas de vous
présenter dans 6 ans
je ne sais pas il vivra verra
termine ce journal retour sur
l'actualité avec un mot de culture
jusqu'au 29 mars la médiathèque du canal
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux propose une
animation innovante originale créée de
la musique à partir de post-it Aurélia
Debussy et Jonathan villeman pour les
images
bleu pour les clochettes ou encore rose
pour la batterie chaque couleur
correspond à un instrument car ici ce
sont les post-it qui créent la musique
stop it est un outil de création
musicale interactif développé par
l'association Lab 212 un collectif
d'artistes au service du développement
de Ford artistique différentes installée
à la médiathèque du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux jusqu'au 29 mars
stop it s'inscrit dans la thématique
culturelle de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
inventons demain le principe cette
positionné donc c'est post-it l'écran
quadrillé en fait sert à avoir une
hauteur de notes différentes puisque la
verticale correspond à la hauteur de la
note et l'horizontale correspond comme
une partition en fait au déroulement du
morceau en lui-même et après le morceau
est joué en boucle on a un écran en fait
blanc sur lequel est projeté un écran
quadrillé enfin des postes de
différentes couleurs et on utilise
également un séquenceur informatique et
une caméra en fait c'est grâce à la
caméra qu'on va reconnaître le
positionnement du post-it et la couleur
du post-it l'utilisateur intervient en
direct sur sa création en déplaçant en
retirant ou ajoutant des post-it une
fonction permet d'enregistrer ses
compositions et de les retrouver sur le
site de l'installation
le 7 8 lecture revient demain vendredi à
la présentation Olivier Maniscalco je
vous retrouverai dimanche 19h45 pour 4h
sur cette nouvelle soirée électorale du
second tour donc les municipales à
suivre toujours sur TVfil 78 très bonne
soirée